お願いしますやりましょうか
はぁ2
[音楽]
ああああああ
me7
うん
meme
ni
me
ムード
ああああああ
wh
ん
me
ああああああ
グリーンなの作れたあああ
[拍手]
今日をもってを試合まで
ウェッジないのでうわぁ野菜の伝書つまり
ましたーーー
20回くらいあって増ございましたこれで
始まる松井原発しております最初で最後の
ブルームチームな推移
よくこの忙しい夏の北皆さん時間作って
いる家を買ってくださっで持ち上げます
また車それかそんなでもうちょっと時間
あるので気が抜けないようにはい調整
改造でありましょう ua こんな感じ
ラリマー
簡単すぎて来ねーうん無理です
ださぁい
[拍手]
はいという意味で本当にみなさん
ありがとうございます
以上 c と思うんですよみんなみんな
忙しい中時間作ってくれて夜中とかに
集まって
バスケ少しでも何かこう言いクレイが
できるようによって練習したのでぜひ皆
さん今日の本番を楽しみにしていて
ください試合はですね生配信でこちらの
チャンネルで肇社長のチャンネルでも配信
しますのでぜひ見てください詳しい時間が
書いてあると思います
[音楽]
勝てるかな
いや買って行って買ってるわけないじゃ
ないですかもしこれで感じたら僕立つ
youtube やってませんプロに入っ
てます珍現象部というかいい試合もしたい
んですけどもあの
楽しい普通にやっても勝てるわけないので
ぜひ楽しいゲームにしようと思います
もちろんバスケットに真剣に取り組みます
またルールとかなというふうな毎日本日
ありますのでぜひご覧くださいじゃあん
ん
分
[音楽]
ん
4日
[音楽]